welcome to the gates show today
Howie Mendel nurses who want to be
actresses a man who has never seen any -
hey what's his deal
thinks he's got a talk show every time
somebody pulls up to the gate he an
abusive it's weird
is he retarded worse eight hours a day I
got a spin with this guy oh you should
think about gardening we had an opening
man well quit his wife was murdered you
know what I am gonna think about that
yeah later man see you weirdo Wow big
crab okay well everyone this bit is
called the worst parking spot on the lot
all right let's check out well you
interested in who has different parking
spots on a lot okay let's see what
producer Jerry Monroe has bad days
Jerry Monroe let's see Oh his assistant
not is good all right let but still not
bad right okay Judd Nelson times are not
so good for Judd Nelson let me on the
lot now I'm Ben Stiller Ben Stiller this
is so exciting but why are you wearing a
mask
well the Jag ABS like you don't
recognize me what a coupe having you on
my show please take off the mask so we
can see it's you know come on we need
big stars like ink so we can compete
with the big boys this is sweeps you
know Kimmel had Matt Damon again No take
the mask off now what are you doing
saying come on I need you I've seen all
three staff not the face cuz I'm on TV
I'm a performer competing oh I'm pretty
with the pretty poor fools just take the
mask off
you're late you miss Ben Stiller what
really Halle Mandel three o'clock Howie
Mandel we'd love getting big stars like
you on the show oh I have so many
questions
but I don't show I don't have time I'm
going into the lot I gotta go got a
meeting come on you must have so many
great stories about those sexy ladies
who work with juicy stories you know
what I'll tell you once I got one minute
one's a story oh great great
from Plymouth feel or No Deal okay but
make it juicy please
juicy yeah one day I'm backstage and the
model number 26 the whole thing
just go fix this
so basically that was a deal and that's
the story so I got a run I got an
appointment
see ya come on story you idiot you know
what I'm gonna do to you because you
know you want to start with some money
start with me security security
Oh tonight's show with today's show it's
great we had been step oh this is great
we've got a phone and gas Mel Gibson